Back before the pandemic, Andrea worked at a bakery under the convention hotel. At first, it was fine, waiting on the conventioneers.
在疫情爆发前，安德烈亚曾在会议酒店楼下的面包店工作。起初，接待参会者感觉还行。
But then you start to dread them. I mean, absolutely. You're like, no, not another convention. They just flipped me out. I was just listening and watching them. I'm getting them their croissants and their coffee.
但后来你开始害怕他们了。我是说，绝对是这样。你会觉得，不，又是另一个会议。他们让我抓狂。我只是在听着看着他们。我给他们拿羊角面包和咖啡。
Fact is, when people are together with others of their own kind, they act differently.
事实是，当人们和同类聚在一起时，他们的行为会变得不同。
This thing happens. I mean, you're so focused into this one aspect of your life that you just sort of become-- that you just absorb into that whole facet of your life.
这种事会发生。我是说，你太专注于生活的这一个方面了，以至于你变得——你只是沉浸在生活的那个方面里。
You become that facet of your life.
你变成了你生活的那个侧面。
You become that facet of your life, yeah.
你变成了你生活的那个侧面，是的。
If one Mary Kay saleswoman walks up to your bakery counter, you don't think twice about it. But 90 of them? That's something completely different.
如果有一个玫琳凯推销员走到你的面包柜台前，你不会多想。但如果是90个呢？那完全是另一回事。
And so there's this excitement. They're really bubbly. And they've got all this bright colored makeup on-- pinks, blues. Just--
所以有一种兴奋感。她们真的很活泼。她们化着那种亮色的妆容——粉色、蓝色。只是——
Oh, of course. Because they're in the convention with their peers. So they have to impress each other. It's not even like they're--
哦，当然。因为她们和同伴们在一起开会。所以她们必须给彼此留下深刻印象。这甚至不像她们是——
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
You're right.
你说得对。
It's not like they're undercover, like, oh, we can go to a convention and not wear makeup. I mean, they were just made up to the nines. I mean, it was crazy. So I'm just looking at them in line. I have never seen more makeup in my entire life. But they were just covered. And just the most awkward-- I mean, everything looked like it was a mistake. Just the most awkward, strange colors. And just things I would--
这不像是在卧底，好像是，哦，我们可以去参加会议而不化妆。我的意思是，她们化了浓妆。真是太疯狂了。我只是在排队时看着她们。我这辈子从没见过这么多的化妆品。但她们全都涂满了。而且是最尴尬的——我的意思是，一切看起来都像是个错误。尽是最尴尬、最奇怪的颜色。还有一些我——
Oh, Andrea, that just goes to show how far from the light you are, just how far you are from the Mary Kay way.
哦，安德烈亚，这正好说明你离光明有多远，你离“玫琳凯之道”有多远。
I know.
我知道。
Math teachers make me particularly nervous because math is my nemesis. I'm awful at math. And I thought, OK, you're working at the bakery counter. They can't hurt you. They're not going to quiz you. You're not going to have algebra. No, I tell them their amount. And then they give me their money. And I'm sitting there, trying to figure it out. And then all of a sudden, they're like, well wait, let me give you $0.05, and then you can give me this back.
数学老师让我特别紧张，因为数学是我的克星。我不擅长数学。我想，好吧，你在面包柜台工作。她们伤不了你。她们不会考你。你不会遇到代数。不，我告诉她们总价。然后她们把钱给我。我坐在那里，试图算清楚。然后突然间，她们说，等等，让我给你5美分，这样你就能找我多少钱了。
And totally, by the end of the day, my drawer was totally off because they'd just blow my mind at the last minute. Plus I hate math, so then I'm getting really nervous. I'm like, I can't do this. I can't do this. I'm having flashbacks from seventh grade. failing math. And I'm like, I can't do it. I just can't do it.
完全是这样，到了一天结束时，我的抽屉金额总是对不上，因为她们在最后一刻把我的脑子搞乱了。加上我讨厌数学，所以我变得非常紧张。我想，我做不到。我做不到。我有了七年级数学不及格的闪回。我想，我做不到。我实在做不到。
Was that the worst they did? Did they do little math tricks with the change, like, oh, that's a prime?
那是她们做过最糟糕的事吗？她们会用零钱玩一些数学把戏吗，比如，哦，那个是质数？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters and performers to take a whack at that game. Today's program, Conventions, and who we become when we attend them. Today's program was first broadcast in the early days of our show, back in the 1990s.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、记者和表演者来挑战这个主题。今天的节目是“会议”，以及当我们参加这些会议时我们会变成什么样的人。今天的节目最早是在我们节目的早期，即1990年代播出的。
Act One, Dark Shadows. So back in the '90s, when TV fans wanted to geek out with other TV fans, most were not online. And so it was a big deal to leave their homes and meet in person to do that. We go with one.
第一幕，暗影。回到90年代，当电视迷们想和其他电视迷一起狂热时，大多数人还不上网。所以离开家亲自去见面是一件大事。我们跟随一个人去看看。
Act Two, A Professional Dishwasher. Dishwasher Pete decides to attend the national convention held by the restaurant owners and managers and bigwigs who employ workers like him.
第二幕，职业洗碗工。洗碗工皮特决定参加由那些雇佣像他一样的工人的餐馆老板、经理和显贵们举办的全国会议。
Act Three, When Worlds Collide, a story that starts in a convention center where two different conventions happen to be taking place, where two different people from two different worlds happen to meet, and big things happen as a result. Stay with us.
第三幕，当世界碰撞时，一个故事始于一个会议中心，两个不同的会议恰好同时举行，两个来自不同世界的人恰好相遇，结果发生了大事。请留下来。
Act One, Dark Shadows. Well, it was Katherine who really wanted to go to the Dark Shadows convention. Katherine was the one who was the fanatic. At least, that's what John says.
第一幕，暗影。嗯，是凯瑟琳真的想去参加《暗影》会议。凯瑟琳是那个狂热的人。至少，约翰是这么说的。
It filled something in her. It was almost like she was an empty glass, and Dark Shadows filled her glass. Whatever was missing in her life at that moment, filled her glass. And she could watch it continually and would laugh and roar and got so involved with the characters and--
它填补了她内心的一些东西。就好像她是一个空玻璃杯，而《暗影》填满了她的杯子。无论那时她生命中缺失了什么，都填满了她的杯子。她可以一直看下去，会大笑，会咆哮，并且完全沉浸在角色中，还有——
How many would she watch? Let's just get that fact out there.
她会看多少？让我们把这个事实摆出来。
She would watch eight hours a day.
她一天会看八个小时。
Eight hours of Dark Shadows a day.
每天八小时的《暗影》。
Eight hours a day. Approximately eight hours a day.
每天八小时。大约每天八小时。
Damn.
该死。
Eight hours a day, every day, of the slowest, creakiest TV show ever. Dark Shadows, you might recall, is the Gothic soap opera that ran from 1966 to 1971. The main character is an avuncular vampire named Barnabas Collins. The storyline shifts from the 19th century to groovy '60s America at its most mod. Its kind of Wuthering Heights meets Austin Powers. Much later, years after we first broadcast this story, in fact, Tim Burton did a film version. It starred Johnny Depp. Anyway, eight hours a day of it, 1,275 episodes in all, beginning on a train.
每天八小时，每一天，看着有史以来最慢、最老掉牙的电视剧。你可能还记得，《暗影》是从1966年播到1971年的哥特式肥皂剧。主角是一个叫巴纳巴斯·柯林斯的慈祥吸血鬼。故事情节从19世纪转换到最时髦的60年代美国。有点像是《呼啸山庄》遇到了《王牌大贱谍》。很久以后，事实上是在我们首次播出这个故事多年后，蒂姆·波顿拍了一个电影版。由约翰尼·德普主演。总之，每天八小时，一共1275集，从火车上开始。
My name is Victoria Winters. My journey is beginning, a journey that will bring me to a strange and dark place, to the edge of the sea, high atop Widow's Hill, a house called Collinwood, a world I've never known with people I've never met.
我叫维多利亚·温特斯。我的旅程开始了，一段旅程将带我到一个陌生而黑暗的地方，去往海边，在那寡妇山顶上，一座叫柯林伍德的房子，一个我从未见过的人所居住的世界，一个我从未了解的世界。
Dear Katherine, it's now 3 o'clock in the morning. And I'm on an Amtrak train heading towards New York. I think right about now, I'm in Syracuse, Ohio. I'm thinking about you. I'm thinking about how this was all your idea to go to the Dark Shadows convention. True, I introduced you to the show. But you're the one who really took it to heart. I feel like I'm going on a journey somehow, the journey to meet people that-- I don't know-- maybe they'll have something in common with me.
亲爱的凯瑟琳，现在是凌晨3点。我正在前往纽约的美国国铁火车上。我想现在我应该在俄亥俄州的雪城。我在想你。我在想这一切去参加《暗影》会议的想法都是你的主意。诚然，是我把你带入这部剧的。但你是那个真正把它放在心上的人。我觉得我好像正在踏上一段旅程，去见那些——我不知道——也许他们会和我有什么共同点的人。
When she said she wasn't going to go, I had to think, do I really want to go to this convention? Is this something I still really need to do? And I thought about it. And I thought, I have been thinking about going to this convention since December. It's August now. I have been talking about going to this convention. It's been on my calendar. I've been preparing. I've been buying clothes for the convention. I've been saving money that-- like, I've been eating ramen noodles for lunch. And I'm going, of course I'm going to go to this convention. Even though this show is just a show to me, I really want to go. I want to talk about Dark Shadows with other people that like Dark Shadows.
当她说她不去了，我不得不思考，我真的想去参加这个会议吗？这是我仍然真正需要做的事情吗？我思考过了。我想，从12月起我就一直在想去参加这个会议。现在是8月了。我一直在谈论去参加这个会议。它已经在我的日历上了。我一直在准备。我一直在为会议买衣服。我一直在存钱——比如，我一直在吃方便面作为午餐。所以我在想，我当然要参加这个会议。即使这部剧对我来说只是一部剧，我真的想去。我想和其他喜欢《暗影》的人谈论《暗影》。
Regular listeners to This American Life may remember one Halloween, producer Nancy Updike and I visited John and his friends, Thax and Erica, during their weekly ritual of watching Dark Shadows. And I'm here to tell you, when you watch several hours of this, it's boring, it's slow. The acting is terrible. The plot lines are preposterous. And apparently, they take months, sometimes years, to resolve.
《美国生活》的常客可能还记得，有一个万圣节，制作人南希·厄普代克和我拜访了约翰和他的朋友们，萨克斯和艾丽卡，在他们每周观看《暗影》的仪式期间。我在这里告诉你，当你连续看几个小时这个节目时，它很无聊，很慢。演技很糟糕。剧情荒谬至极。而且显然，它们需要几个月，有时几年才能解决。
But it's live TV. And it feels like live TV, which means that if you watch long enough, you see people forget lines. Scripts are left on beds during scenes. Prop guys get caught on screen. You can see them through doorways. Flies settle on the actors' faces during close ups. And this is part of what John and his friends love when they watch. At the time when we did that story, John was watching six hours a week.
但这是直播电视。它感觉就像直播电视，这意味着如果你看的时间够长，你会看到人们忘词。场景中剧本被留在床上。道具师被抓到上镜。你可以通过门口看到他们。在近景拍摄时，苍蝇停在演员脸上。这就是约翰和他的朋友们在观看时所喜欢的一部分。我们做那个故事的时候，约翰每周看六个小时。
You notice the littlest things you wouldn't notice in a regular show. We noticed tonight that people have stopped knocking on the door three times. They're now knocking on the door four times.
你注意到了你在常规节目中不会注意到的小事情。我们今晚注意到人们不再敲门三次了。他们现在敲门四次。
I'll go out the back way.
我会从后门走。
No, no, you won't. You'll stay right here.
不，不，你不会。你会留在这里。
But Bethel, they'll make me go back if they find--
但贝瑟尔，如果他们发现——他们会让我回去的。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
So John thinks they had a lengthy meeting deciding that you have to have four knocks instead of three to spice up the plot a little bit. It's more exciting.
所以约翰认为他们开了一个冗长的会议，决定必须敲四下而不是三下，以增加一点剧情。这更刺激。
The new director said we've got to get rid of the old ways. Things are going to change around here. No more of this three knocks stuff.
新导演说我们必须摆脱旧习惯。这里的事情要变了。不再有这种敲三下的东西了。
Oh, Glenda, it's happening again.
哦，格伦达，它又发生了。
So John goes to New York on the train, alone, to a convention hotel on Times Square. Katherine doesn't go because she got a job, which tends to cut into people's Dark Shadows habit in a rather major way.
于是约翰独自一人坐火车去纽约，住进时代广场的一家会议酒店。凯瑟琳没去，因为她找了份工作，这往往会以相当大的程度影响人们的《暗影》习惯。
I'll be honest, I was really petrified because I was alone in New York. I don't know anybody. And there are probably about 400 people all waiting in line to go into this banquet hall to start the ceremonies, the opening Dark Shadow convention ceremonies. And I'm walking around, and I know that everybody here, I can walk up to them and start talking about Dark Shadows. But I don't know if I want to at this point.
老实说，我很害怕，因为我独自在纽约。我不认识任何人。可能有大约400人在排队准备进入这个宴会厅开始仪式，也就是《暗影》会议的开幕式。我四处走动，我知道这里的每个人，我可以走过去和他们开始谈论《暗影》。但我不知道我此时是否想这样做。
And the last time I'd actually remembered that feeling was when I had first gone into a gay bar by myself and felt like this was something I had to do by myself. I was all alone. And there I was, in this room of people that we all had something in common.
我上次真正记得那种感觉是当我第一次独自走进一家同性恋酒吧，觉得这是我必须独自去做的事情。我孤身一人。我就在那里，在这一群我们都有共同点的人中。
You had just come out.
你刚刚出柜。
I had just come out. We all had something in common. I knew that all these people, we had a similar life experience.
我刚刚出柜。我们都有共同点。我知道所有这些人，我们有相似的生活经历。
You have one thing in common.
你们有一个共同点。
We have one thing in common.
我们有一个共同点。
For example, with the gay bar, you can't just walk up to somebody and say, so you're a homosexual too. Me too.
例如，在同性恋酒吧，你不能直接走到某人面前说，哦，你也是同性恋啊。我也是。
Testing. I'm now at the convention. And-- hold on.
测试。我现在在会议上。还有——等等。
You use that word. Not yet.
你用了那个词。还没到呢。
Right now, I'm in the grand ballroom at the Marriott. It's opulent beyond belief. I mean, there are four large chandeliers. And there are probably about, I would say, a little bit over 500 people here right now. And they're doing a retrospective on some of the Dark Shadows actors who had passed on. It's just funny. There are 500 people sitting in this grand ballroom watching TV.
现在，我在万豪酒店的大宴会厅。这里富丽堂皇得难以置信。我的意思是，有四个大吊灯。这里现在大概有超过500人。他们正在做一些已经去世的《暗影》演员的回顾展。这很有趣。有500人坐在大宴会厅里看电视。
Not yet. That's how Humbert makes his vocabulary.
还没到呢。那是亨伯特创造词汇的方式。
We all go into the ballroom to watch TV.
我们都进入宴会厅看电视。
What?
什么？
That's the opening ceremony.
那是开幕式。
So it's 500, and there's a little tiny TV on the stage?
所以是500人，而台上有一个小小的电视？
No, no, no. This is huge. The TV is huge. I mean--
不，不，不。这是巨大的。电视是巨大的。我的意思是——
Oh, it would be like a--
哦，那就像一个——
There's a little black and white 12 inch at the front that we all gather around.
前面有一个12英寸的小黑白电视，我们都围在它周围。
Because when you think about it, it is a convention about watching TV.
因为当你想到它的时候，它确实是一个关于看电视的会议。
Yeah, and I hadn't thought about that until that exact moment. I was going, it's just sort of something to talk to people.
是的，直到那一刻我还没想到这一点。我在想，这只是和人聊天的一种东西。
Then it occurred to you, I'm here to watch TV.
然后你意识到，我是来这看电视的。
I'm here to watch TV, and I'm here to talk to people about watching TV.
我是来这看电视的，也是来和人们聊看电视的。
Even terrifying perhaps.
甚至可能很可怕。
The other thing I was there for was to watch-- this was so amazing. People make Dark Shadows videos. They make their own Dark Shadows videos.
我来这里的另一件事是为了看——这太神奇了。人们制作《暗影》视频。他们制作他们自己的《暗影》视频。
You mean like using footage from the original--
你是说使用原始视频的镜头——
No, no, no, they create new Dark Shadows videos.
不，不，不，他们创作新的《暗影》视频。
New Dark Shadows episodes-- they make new episodes themselves?
新的《暗影》剧集——他们自己制作新的剧集？
Right, they make new episodes themselves.
对，他们自己制作新的剧集。
They get costumes and build sets?
他们准备服装并搭建布景吗？
Oh my god, there was this one thing. It was amazing. It was a parody of the show, but a parody like if you watched it right now, you would go-- it could be funny. But it's all inside jokes if you watch Dark Shadows. It's the only way you would think this is funny. But it was so elaborate. They had completely rebuilt the set of Barnabas's drawing room-- completely. And then another set was in a graveyard. And they had completely done the graveyard.
哦天哪，有一个东西。太惊人了。那是该剧的戏仿，但如果你现在看它，你会觉得——它可能很有趣。但如果你看《暗影》，那全是内部梗。只有这样你才会觉得这很有趣。但它太复杂了。他们完全重建了巴纳巴斯的客厅布景——完全重建。然后另一个布景在墓地。他们完全做出了墓地。
This one man played three different characters. And it was edited like it was completely professional. I mean, they must have spent a ton of money. They had gotten one of the original cast members to come and be in the video. It was so incredibly elaborate. And it was like 45 minutes long, and it was good. And then it was like, to think I'm sitting there, going, this is really good.
这一个人扮演了三个不同的角色。它的剪辑就像完全专业的一样。我的意思是，他们一定花了很多钱。他们找来了原始演员之一来参与视频拍摄。它非常复杂。而且有45分钟长，而且很好。然后就像是，想到我坐在那里，想着，这真的很好。
Your outfit at this point?
你当时的装束呢？
Well, I had put on my red burgundy, crushed velvet Pierre Cardin jacket that I'd gotten at the Salvation Army for 5 bucks. It had a little water spot on the back of it. I had put on my rhinestone brooch that looks sort of like a flaring sun with this big, huge rhinestone which I--
好吧，我穿上了我那件深勃艮第色的压皱天鹅绒皮尔·卡丹夹克，是我在救世军以5美元买的。背面有个小水渍。我戴上了我的水钻胸针，看起来有点像一个耀眼的太阳，中间有一个大大的水钻，我——
Right in the middle of your collar.
就在你衣领的正中间。
Right in the middle, which I had pinned to my silk shirt and black pants and my shoes, which were Quentin Collins shoes from the 1960s show. I mean, I found these--
就在中间，我把它别在丝绸衬衫和黑裤子上，还有我的鞋子，那是60年代节目里的昆汀·柯林斯鞋。我的意思是，我发现了这些——
John was the only one there dressed up, at least the first day. Everyone else was in shorts, summer clothes, casual clothes, which makes the person wonder, am I the weirdo? John would get on the elevator wearing his convention name with non-convention hotel guests.
约翰是那里唯一打扮的人，至少第一天是这样。其他人都穿着短裤、夏装、休闲装，这让当事人怀疑，我是怪胎吗？约翰会戴着他的会议胸牌，和非会议酒店客人一起进电梯。
And they would look at me. Then they would look at my badge. And then they would look at me again. I felt at that moment, I'm like, I'm the weirdo. I'm the weirdo in the elevator. I'm at a Dark Shadows convention.
他们会看着我。然后他们会看我的胸牌。然后他们会再看着我。那一刻我感到，我想，我是个怪胎。我是电梯里的怪胎。我在参加《暗影》会议。
This feeling may be more extreme at a Dark Shadows convention, but frankly, it is common to any convention, standing on the elevator, with your badge, separated from the rest of your tribe, surrounded by civilians. It's easy to feel like a freak, even if you're just a math teacher.
这种感觉在《暗影》会议上可能更强烈，但坦率地说，这在任何会议上都很常见，站在电梯里，戴着胸牌，与你的部落其余部分分开，被平民包围。很容易让人觉得自己是个怪胎，即使你只是个数学老师。
But there are freaks, and there are freaks. John, for example, would not get in the 800-person five-hour line to get autographs from the stars. On the other hand, in three days, in the world's most exciting, vibrant city, he never left the hotel. And then he went to this panel where all of these issues were resolved. Stars from Dark Shadows were there, answering detailed questions from the audience.
但怪胎和怪胎是不一样的。比如约翰，就不会去排那个800人、5小时的队去从明星那里拿签名。另一方面，在三天里，在世界上最激动人心、充满活力的城市里，他从未离开过酒店。然后他去了这个所有问题都得到解决的小组。来自《暗影》的明星们在那里，回答观众的详细问题。
But this woman gets up at this panel discussion. And she has a pre-prepared statement. And the statement is-- it was like, I want to thank all of you for all the joy you've given me through my years. And she said, "When I watch Dark Shadows, I want to take the high road. I want to think of the things Dark Shadows has given me, how it's taught me to forgive, how it's taught me the joy of friendship, how it's taught me that you need to go on from bad situations."
但这个女人在这个小组讨论会上站了起来。她有一个预先准备好的声明。声明是——它就像是，我想感谢你们所有人这些年来给予我的所有快乐。她说，“当我看《暗影》时，我想走高尚路线。我想思考《暗影》给予我的东西，它如何教我宽恕，它如何教我友谊的快乐，它如何教我你需要从糟糕的情况中走出来。”
And then she said, "And most people will listen to this, and they will think that I'm a crackpot. And if I'm a crackpot, so be it." And then she screams into the mic, "Dark Shadows lives!" And you see this look on all the actors' faces, like, fear, like a little bit of fear. [LAUGHS]
然后她说，“大多数人听到这个，他们会认为我是个疯子。如果我是疯子，那就随它去吧。”然后她对着麦克风尖叫，“《暗影》万岁！”你会看到所有演员脸上的表情，就像恐惧，像一点点的恐惧。[笑声]
But it dawned on me, this was the statement that I had felt, that I had been feeling a little bit. And she is standing up in this room full of people and proclaiming, "I am a crackpot." And I was thinking, well, I'm sort of a crackpot, too. And here she was. It was sort of like the alcoholic getting up at the alcohol convention, saying, "I am an alcoholic." [LAUGHS]
但这让我意识到，这就是我一直在感觉的声明，我已经感觉了一点点。她站在这个挤满人的房间里，宣告，“我是个疯子。”而我在想，好吧，我也算是个疯子。她就在这儿。这有点像酗酒者在酗酒者会议上站起来说，“我是个酗酒者。”[笑声]
And I thought. I love that. And I was just like, God, this is what this whole convention is about. We're like all these misfits. And at this point, I was feeling the sense of community. And I was feeling, in the sea of crackpots, I'm a crackpot with them. I am brother. I am with you. [LAUGHS]
我想。我喜欢那个。我只是觉得，上帝，这就是整个会议的全部意义。我们就像所有这些异类。此时，我感受到了社区意识。我觉得，在疯子的海洋里，我和他们一样是疯子。我是兄弟。我和你们在一起。[笑声]
But John, I mean, but you sort of saw her as being nuts.
但约翰，我的意思是，你还是有点觉得她疯了。
Right.
对。
But you felt she was speaking for you when she said that?
但当她说那话时，你觉得她在为你说话吗？
I felt an empathy with her. And just not that I'm going to be the one going up there screaming, "I am a crackpot. Dark Shadows rules."
我感觉到和她有共鸣。并不是说我会成为那个站上去尖叫，“我是疯子。《暗影》统治一切”的人。
No, you've chosen to say it to 400,000 people over the radio.
不，你选择了在广播里对40万人说出来。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Oh god, I'm going to pass out. Dark Shadows rules. I've said it. I've said it, Ira.
哦天哪，我要晕过去了。《暗影》统治一切。我说了。我说了，艾拉。
Do you want to say it louder, John?
你想再大声一点说吗，约翰？
No.
不。
You can.
你可以的。
I don't want to say it any louder.
我不想再大声说了。
Oh, come on.
哦，来吧。
I don't want to say it any louder.
我不想再大声说了。
Do you want to stand up? We can--
你想站起来吗？我们可以——
No, I don't want to say it. It's OK. I've said it. That's all I want to say.
不，我不想说。没关系。我已经说了。这就是我想说的一切。
I spoke with Chris Crowley, who worked as a facilities manager at the Moscone Center in San Francisco, one of the biggest convention centers in the world. And he told me that there's a kind of life cycle to conventions that happen in predictable phases. The first day, everybody's disoriented. People get lost. People are still individuals at that point. They're not a group just yet.
我和克里斯·克劳利谈过，他在旧金山的莫斯康中心担任设施经理，那是世界上最大的会议中心之一。他告诉我，会议有一种生命周期，发生在可预测的阶段。第一天，每个人都迷失方向。人们迷路。此时人们仍然是个体。他们还不是一个群体。
The second day, people start to group and begin to bond, form those little packs of people. And by the third day of the convention, there's definite friendships that are made and groups of people that are following each other. And you start to recognize who your peers are. And you kind of-- you create or they create their own little herd mentality, if you will. And all this happened to John. On the first day, he didn't want to talk to anybody. He felt like a loner. By the second, he found some friends at the volunteer desk and the costume ball.
第二天，人们开始分组并开始建立联系，形成那些小团体。到会议的第三天，肯定会结下友谊，并出现彼此跟随的人群。你开始识别谁是你的同类。你有点——你创造或他们创造了属于他们自己的小群体思维。这一切都发生在约翰身上。第一天，他不想和任何人说话。他觉得自己是个孤独者。到了第二天，他在志愿者服务台和化装舞会上找到了一些朋友。
And these people seemed like they were pretty fun. So some of the people I had talked to during the day, I said, let's all go back to my room. I've got two bottles of Merlot, and let's all get drunk and talk about Dark Shadows.
这些人看起来很风趣。所以我白天和一些人聊过，我说，大家回我的房间吧。我有两瓶梅洛，让我们喝醉，聊聊《暗影》。
But then, sadly, John discovered the inevitable third phase of any convention. He got sick of it. In this case, too much TV, too much merchandise, too many pictures and videos of Dark Shadows going everywhere all the time, too much sharing. He woke up the morning of the third day with a cheap wine hangover, never wanting to talk about Barnabas Collins again, or at least, for the foreseeable future. He had to force himself to go downstairs to the final banquet, which he had already paid $45 to attend.
但后来，可悲的是，约翰发现了任何会议不可避免的第三阶段。他厌烦了。在这种情况下，电视看太多了，商品太多了，关于《暗影》的图片和视频到处都是，分享得太多了。他第三天早晨醒来，带着廉价葡萄酒的宿醉，再也不想谈论巴纳巴斯·柯林斯了，或者至少，在可预见的未来不想谈了。他不得不强迫自己下楼去参加最后的宴会，他已经为此支付了45美元。
And this other guy was sitting next to me. And we talked a little bit about the show. And it was like he started talking to me. And he was from Long Island. And he asked me where I was from. I said Chicago. And he said he had gone through Chicago. And he changed the subject to sports and about the Bulls. And I don't talk about sports ever. I don't know anything about sports. I don't even follow the Bulls when the championships are going on.
另一个人坐在我旁边。我们聊了一点关于剧集的事。就像他开始和我说话。他是长岛人。他问我从哪里来。我说芝加哥。他说他去过芝加哥。他把话题转到了体育和公牛队上。我从来不谈体育。我什么都不懂。即使在冠军赛期间，我也不关注公牛队。
Which actually is very, very hard. It's like trying to ignore Christmas if you live in Chicago.
这实际上非常非常难。这就像如果你住在芝加哥却试图忽略圣诞节一样。
It's everywhere. And I found myself sitting with this person at this convention, talking about the Bulls, talking about the Bulls in Chicago. And-- [LAUGHS]
它无处不在。我发现自己和这个人在会议上坐着，谈论公牛队，在芝加哥谈论公牛队。还有——[笑声]
In your normal life, if somebody were trying to talk to you about sports, you'd be thinking to yourself, I wish I could be talking about something like Dark Shadows.
在你的正常生活中，如果有人试图和你谈论体育，你会对自己说，我希望我能谈论像《暗影》这样的东西。
Right, and there I was, I was engaging him in talking about the Bulls. And I was saying, when you were in London, did the Bulls championship go on? Where were you? Are you a Bulls fan? Are people talking-- and I was changing the subject. Then we talked about the Cubs. I don't talk about the Cubs.
对，而我当时就在那儿，我在和他谈论公牛队。我在说，当你在伦敦时，公牛队冠军赛在进行吗？你在哪儿？你是公牛队球迷吗？人们在谈论——我在转换话题。然后我们谈论了小熊队。我不谈论小熊队。
When John Connors got home after a 24-hour train ride, he opened the door and heard the click of his video machine. He had recorded six hours of Dark Shadows. The day he returned, he said he wasn't sure he'd be able to watch them. Three days later, he watched five.
当约翰·康纳斯坐了24小时火车回到家后，他打开门，听到了录像机的咔哒声。他录了六个小时的《暗影》。他说他回去的那天不确定自己是否能看完它们。三天后，他看了五集。
Act Two.
第二幕。
I'm a dishwasher. And having worked in restaurants for over a decade, it would only make sense that I attend the National Restaurant Association's annual gathering. But it's not an organization that welcomes restaurant employees-- quite the contrary.
我是个洗碗工。在餐馆工作了十多年，我去参加全国餐馆协会的年度聚会也就说得通了。但这不是一个欢迎餐馆员工的组织——恰恰相反。
That's Dishwasher Pete, writer and publisher of the zine Dishwasher, which is this original and very funny account of his life as a dishwasher traveling from place to place on a small mission to wash dishes in all 50 states, plus whatever dishwashing topics and stories he feels like writing about. He's visiting the National Restaurant Association, which is made up of restaurant owners, managers, and suppliers, and a force to be reckoned with in Washington, DC.
那是洗碗工皮特，杂志《洗碗工》的作者和出版人，这是他作为一名洗碗工从一个地方旅行到另一个地方的原创且非常有趣的记录，小使命是在所有50个州洗碗，加上任何他想写的洗碗主题和故事。他正在参观全国餐馆协会，该协会由餐馆老板、经理和供应商组成，在华盛顿特区是一股不可忽视的力量。
When we first aired this story, when he actually made this visit, it was actually 1997, a long time ago. Bill Clinton was president. And at the time, the National Restaurant Association had fought hard against Bill Clinton's national healthcare proposal. Newt Gingrich, who was Speaker of the House back then-- you may remember-- stated that their lobbying-- the National Restaurant Association's lobbying was key to defeating the Clinton health plan. The National Restaurant Association was also an important opponent of the minimum wage, which it still is today.
我们第一次播出这个故事，当他真正进行这次访问时，实际上是1997年，很久以前了。比尔·克林顿是总统。当时，全国餐馆协会坚决反对比尔·克林顿的国家医疗保健提案。纽特·金里奇，当时的众议院议长——你可能还记得——曾表示他们的游说——全国餐馆协会的游说是击败克林顿医保计划的关键。全国餐馆协会也是最低工资的重要反对者，今天依然如此。
So if this group that works so hard against the interests of me and my restaurant colleagues were going to hold a powwow, I felt it my responsibility to be there.
所以，如果这个如此努力反对我和我的餐馆同事利益的组织要举行聚会，我觉得我有责任出现在那里。
Riding up the escalator into the middle of Chicago's McCormick Place Convention Center, I was immediately overwhelmed. On display was everything imaginable concerning the food service industry, every sort of cooking and serving appliance utensil, food products, menu designs, everything. Each booth was highly specialized. If they didn't have an impressive array of napkin rings, then they were peddling theme outfits so that restaurant staff could dress up like pirates or clowns.
乘自动扶梯进入芝加哥麦考密克会展中心，我立刻被淹没了。展出的是关于食品服务业的一切可想象的东西，各种烹饪和服务的器具器皿、食品、菜单设计，应有尽有。每个展位都高度专业化。如果他们没有令人印象深刻的餐巾环系列，那么他们就在兜售主题服装，这样餐馆员工就可以装扮成海盗或小丑。
I had come expecting to find groupings of restaurant owners smoking their cigars, rubbing their bellies, and exchanging tales of how they'd stuck it to their employees. So where were they? In the meantime, there was something on my agenda, something that's always on my agenda-- free food. Plenty of food products were available for sampling. I nibbled my way along-- a hunk of chocolate here, a veggie burger there, waffles, chicken tenders, stir fry, jelly beans. This part didn't seem so bad.
我来的时候以为会看到一群餐馆老板抽着雪茄，摸着肚子，交流他们是如何剥削员工的故事。那么他们在哪里呢？与此同时，我的议程上有一些东西，总是出现在我的议程上——免费食物。有很多食品可以免费品尝。我一路吃着——一块巧克力，一个素食汉堡，华夫饼，鸡柳，炒菜，软糖。这一部分看起来还不赖。
That was, until I arrived at one of the booths giving away free beer. There was fierce competition to reach the bar. Being jostled from both sides by guys in suits was a bit unsettling. I hadn't planned to be so informal with these people. I came to the show to be inconspicuous and to inspect, not to socialize and rub shoulders with folks who might otherwise be my boss.
直到我走到其中一个免费提供啤酒的展位。到达吧台的竞争非常激烈。被两侧穿西装的家伙挤来挤去有点令人不安。我没打算和这些人这么不拘礼节。我来参加展会是为了保持低调和考察，而不是为了社交和与可能成为我老板的人勾肩搭背。
After I was finally served, I stood back and watched the boss types push and shove their way to the free beer. I turned and watched another crowd of boss types clamoring to receive free plastic key chains at another booth. This, to me, was weird. I had expected that with this many boss types in one hall, the air would be thick with authority. Instead, these authority figures were giddy over receiving plastic trinkets. It was disturbing to see all these boss types away from their restaurants, like being in the sixth grade and seeing your teacher walking down the street, holding her boyfriend's hand. It's just something I don't care to see.
在我终于得到服务后，我退后看着那些老板类型的人挤过人群去拿免费啤酒。我转身看着另一群老板类型的人在另一个展位争抢免费塑料钥匙链。对我来说，这很奇怪。我曾预期在一个大厅里有这么多老板类型的人，气氛会充满权威感。相反，这些权威人物对得到塑料小玩意儿感到晕眩。看着所有这些老板类型的人离开他们的餐馆真是令人不安，就像在上六年级时看到你的老师走在街上，牵着她男朋友的手。这只是我不愿意看到的东西。
But while the gathering of the boss type seemed rather innocuous, I assumed the capitalist parade would be in full swing, as I headed to the convention's keynote address, given by Republican Senator Bob Dole.
但当老板类型的聚会看起来相当无害时，我以为资本主义游行将全面展开，我前往会议的主题演讲，由共和党参议员鲍勃·多尔发表。
So we shouldn't forget for a moment that we live in the greatest country on the face of the Earth.
所以我们永远不应该忘记我们生活在地球上最伟大的国家。
By the time I took my seat at the back of the room, Dole was well underway. I listened. I became confused. I think Dole was confused, too. He was supposed to be giving the keynote address to a group of restaurant tourists. Instead, he gave what amounted to be a campaign speech.
当我坐在房间后面时，多尔的演讲已经进行了一段时间。我听着。我变得困惑了。我想多尔也很困惑。他本应向一群餐馆游客发表主题演讲。相反，他发表的内容相当于竞选演说。
And we shouldn't forget for a moment, the people who came ahead of us made sacrifices for us.
我们永远不应该忘记，那些走在我们前面的人为我们做出了牺牲。
I was desperate for any morsel related to restaurants to come from Dole's mouth. It never came. I began to sense that Dole wasn't quite sure where he was. I had assumed he was yet another political lackey of the National Restaurant Association. But now, he seemed more like the grandfather at a family dinner who babbles incomprehensibly, while the rest of the family is too polite to draw attention to it.
我迫切希望听到多尔口中说出任何与餐馆有关的东西。但从未出现。我开始感觉到多尔不太确定他在哪里。我曾以为他是全国餐馆协会的又一个政治走狗。但现在，他看起来更像是在家庭晚餐上嘟囔着不可理解的话语的祖父，而家人太礼貌了，不好意思引起注意。
As Dole droned on, streams of people, apparently having heard enough, headed for the exits. Then Dole took questions from those remaining. I had hoped to ask him something like, hey, man, why are you and the National Restaurant Association always trying to keep the dishwashers down? But in each of his responses, as he drifted away from the question, I realized, I couldn't ask a snot-nosed question of this absentminded old man, thinking instead, maybe he could provide some grandfatherly advice. Mine was the last question.
当多尔喋喋不休时，人群成群结队地前往出口，显然是听够了。然后多尔回答了剩下的人的问题。我本希望问他像这样的话，嘿，伙计，为什么你和全国餐馆协会总是试图压低洗碗工？但在他的每一个回答中，当他偏离问题时，我意识到，我不能问这个老糊涂冒失的问题，相反，我想，也许他能提供一些祖父般的建议。我是最后一个提问的。
Hello, Mr. Dole. Here at the National Restaurant Association show, I was wondering if you had any words of advice for the dishwashers of the nation.
你好，多尔先生。在这里的全国餐馆协会展会上，我想知道你对全国的洗碗工有什么建议吗？
Just keep washing them, would be my advice.
我的建议就是继续洗碗。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I was excited because mine was the only question he actually answered. Just keep washing. At first, it seemed like a good-natured slap on the back, thumbs up piece of advice. But as the band played on, Dole's words kept echoing through my head. Just keep washing. Yep, just keep washing. Day after day, just keep washing. Week after week, month after month, just keep washing, year after year after year. What the hell kind of advice is that?
我很兴奋，因为我是唯一一个他真正回答的问题。继续洗。起初，这看起来像是一个善意的拍拍背，竖起大拇指的建议。但当乐队继续演奏时，多尔的话在我的脑海里不断回响。继续洗。是的，继续洗。一天又一天，继续洗。一周又一周，一个月又一个月，继续洗，一年又一年。那到底是什么鬼建议？
While Dishwasher Pete searches the National Restaurant Association for traces of the American dream, one that Bob Dole would actually approve of. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
当洗碗工皮特在全国餐馆协会寻找鲍勃·多尔真正赞同的美国梦的痕迹时。这将在芝加哥公共广播电台的一分钟后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a wide variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Conventions. We are in the middle of Act Two, Dishwasher Pete, a real life dishwasher at the convention of the National Restaurant Association.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样的关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“会议”。我们正在进行第二幕，“洗碗工皮特”，一位在全国餐馆协会会议上的真正洗碗工。
Working as a dishwasher, I'm often told, start here and someday you may own your own restaurant. Bosses tell this to dishwashers all the time. And if that's true, that'd mean I was surrounded by tens of thousands of former dishwashers at the restaurant convention.
作为一名洗碗工，我经常被告知，从这里开始，总有一天你可能会拥有自己的餐馆。老板们总是这样告诉洗碗工。如果这是真的，那就意味着在餐馆会议上我有成千上万的前洗碗工被包围。
Do you have much experience washing dishes yourself?
你自己有洗碗的经验吗？
I can't say that I have.
我不能说我有。
Only at home.
只在家里。
You haven't done that in the past?
你过去没有做过吗？
No, that's really not that effective.
没有，那真的不是很有效。
Dishwashers are invisible to most restaurant customers. But why was such an important part of the industry being ignored at this gathering that celebrated every aspect of the restaurant world? I set out to find some of my fellow dishwashers. I stopped passersby, asking them if they've seen any dishwashers walking around. I received one negative response after another. One restaurant owner snidely told me she wouldn't think of bringing her dishwashers to the show.
大多数餐馆顾客看不到洗碗工。但为什么在这个庆祝餐馆世界各个方面的聚会上，如此重要的行业部分却被忽视了呢？我出发去寻找我的一些洗碗同僚。我拦住过路人，问他们有没有看到任何走动的洗碗工。我得到了一个又一个否定的回答。一位餐馆老板尖刻地告诉我，她根本不会考虑带她的洗碗工来参加展会。
But then I realized there was one place I was sure to find some of my dish brethren. Like a moth to the flame, I headed straight for the Hobart display. As the largest manufacturers of commercial dishwashing equipment, Hobart is legendary amongst those of us who wash dishes for a living. Their model dish machines would surely be staffed by real-life dishwashers. Hobart's display was quite a spectacle, buzzing with activity, with free beer and dozens of trippy sales reps wearing matching bright blue shirts. I half expected there to be bikini clad women, lounging atop their display dish machines.
但后来我意识到有一个地方我肯定能找到我的一些洗碗弟兄。像飞蛾扑火一样，我径直走向霍巴特展区。作为最大的商用洗碗设备制造商，霍巴特在我们这些以洗碗为生的人中是传奇。他们的洗碗机模型肯定会有真正的洗碗工来操作。霍巴特的展位相当壮观，活动频繁，有免费啤酒和几十个穿着相配鲜蓝色衬衫的时髦销售代表。我甚至以为会有比基尼女郎在他们的展示洗碗机上躺着。
But my hopes for finding dishwashing camaraderie didn't pan out. First of all, there were no dishwashers operating the machines. In fact, the machines sat idle. And I didn't find much kinship with the Hobart Salesforce. Hobart's Barry Baylock showed off their new sink, the turbo wash, that circulated water to enhance the soaking of pots and pans.
但找到洗碗情谊的希望没有实现。首先，没有洗碗工在操作机器。事实上，机器处于闲置状态。而且我和霍巴特的销售团队没有找到太多亲缘关系。霍巴特的巴里·贝洛克展示了他们的新水槽，“涡轮清洗”，通过循环水来增强浸泡锅碗瓢盆的效果。
With a dish machine, you've got to have somebody to man it. With this, you don't. So you're able to destaff your kitchen, so to speak. So it's a big labor saver. Yes, it's more expensive than a three-compartment sink. But it's less expensive than having a full-time employee. This shows up every day. A full-time employee doesn't.
有了洗碗机，你得有人去操作它。有了这个，你就不需要了。所以你可以解雇你的厨房人员，可以说。所以这是一个很大的劳动力节省工具。是的，它比三格水槽更贵。但它比雇佣一个全职员工便宜。这每天都会出现。全职员工不会。
What do you think about the dishwashers who may be facing layoffs because of a labor saving device such as this?
你对那些可能因为这种节省劳动力的设备而面临裁员的洗碗工有什么看法？
This does not take a very qualified person. It allows one person to do several jobs within a dish room activity, instead of having two people to do two separate jobs. So it actually is going to help out, giving more job security to the person that is working in that dish room area.
这不需要非常合格的人员。它允许一个人在洗碗房活动中完成几项工作，而不是两个人做两项独立的工作。所以它实际上会帮助，给在洗碗房区域工作的人提供更多的就业保障。
Now why would that be?
为什么会那样呢？
Well, because they can do more within the dish room. They can operate the dish machine.
嗯，因为他们可以在洗碗房做更多的事情。他们可以操作洗碗机。
Both Hobart sales reps that I talked to told me that not only have they never held dishwashing jobs, but they hated doing the chore at home. What sort of machine representatives were these? To me, they were like surgeons who hated the sight of blood.
我和我交谈过的两位霍巴特销售代表都告诉我，他们不仅从来没干过洗碗工，而且他们在家里也讨厌做这项杂务。这是什么样的机器代表？对我来说，他们就像讨厌看到血的外科医生。
I let the Hobart display a bit dejected and checked out some of their competitors. The Champion machine companies couldn't have been more different than the Hobart display. They were, unlike the massive bright and chirpy Hobart crew, just a couple of middle-aged guys wearing drab brown suits. I spoke to a guy named Peter for a while, asking if any dishwashers had visited the booth. None had.
我离开霍巴特展区时有点沮丧，并看了看他们的一些竞争对手。冠军机器公司与霍巴特展区大不相同。他们不像庞大、明亮且快乐的霍巴特团队，只是几个穿着暗棕色西装的中年人。我和一个叫彼得的家伙聊了一会儿，问有没有洗碗工来过展位。一个都没有。
As I was about to walk away, he asked if I was Dishwasher Pete. It was kind of spooky. My cover was blown. Peter introduced me to Hank Holt, the president of Champion. He had written me a year prior, requesting a copy of my publication Dishwasher. I kind of can't believe that the company's head honcho would bother to attend such an event. But I was even more surprised that he remembered who I was.
就在我要走开时，他问我是不是洗碗工皮特。这有点诡异。我的身份被揭穿了。彼得把我介绍给了冠军公司的总裁汉克·霍尔特。他一年前给我写过信，要求一份我的刊物《洗碗工》。我有点不敢相信公司的老大会费心参加这样的活动。但我更惊讶的是他还记得我是谁。
Dishwasher Pete goes all-- he goes all over the country, washing dishes. And he writes about them and puts out this little book every week. It's funnier than the devil. The problem, we wanted to put some of his articles on the web page and send them out to some of the consultants and all that. But we have to edit them. They're a little bit spicy for some of them.
洗碗工皮特去——他去全国各地洗碗。他写关于他们的文章，每周发行这本小书。它滑稽得要命。问题是，我们想把他的一些文章放在网页上，发给一些顾问等等。但我们必须编辑它们。对于他们中的一些人来说，它们有点太辛辣了。
How's the show been going for you?
展会进行得怎么样？
The show's been fine. We're not overwhelmed with--
展会一直很好。我们没有被——淹没。
While Hank and I talked dishwashing, I snuck peeks over at the Hobart group. It seemed ridiculous that I had previously scoffed at the Champion guys and thought that I'd find solidarity among the Hobart crew. The Hobart folks now look like the in crowd at high school, the jocks and cheerleaders who were popular, yet shallow. Meanwhile, here were the nerdier Champion guys, who could relate more to where I was coming from, though not entirely.
当汉克和我谈论洗碗时，我偷偷瞄向霍巴特小组。我之前嘲笑冠军队的家伙，以为我会在霍巴特团队中找到团结，这看起来很荒谬。霍巴特的人现在看起来就像高中里的风云人物，那些受欢迎但肤浅的运动员和啦啦队长。与此同时，这里有更书呆子气的冠军队家伙，他们能更多地理解我的处境，尽管不是全部。
But Hank and I did have a good conversation. We were from opposite ends of the spectrum. He, the president of a dish machine company. Me, dishwasher. I still needed to find an actual fellow dish dog.
但汉克和我的谈话进行得很愉快。我们来自光谱的两端。他是洗碗机公司的总裁。我是个洗碗工。我仍然需要找到一个真正的洗碗狗友。
As the show was winding down, I left the crowds and commotion, descending three flights of stairs, heading deep down into the bowels of the convention center until I came upon a door. I push a button next to the door, and moments later, it buzzed open. I wandered through the labyrinth of corridors, peeking around corners, and acting as if I belonged there whenever I encountered someone. Then I heard a familiar hum in the distance.
当展会接近尾声时，我离开人群和骚动，下楼三层，深入到会议中心的深处，直到我来到一扇门前。我按下门旁的一个按钮，片刻之后，门发出嗡嗡声打开了。我在迷宫般的走廊里徘徊，窥视拐角处，无论我遇到谁，都表现得像是我属于那里。然后我听到远处传来熟悉的嗡嗡声。
How are you doing?
你好吗？
All right. So you're the man behind the scenes, huh? You're the man behind the scenes washing the dishes?
好吧。你是幕后黑手，对吧？你是那个在幕后洗碗的人吗？
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
His name is Jesse, and he was working alone in the cavernous dish room, unloading dishes from a huge 30-foot long conveyor belt style machine, just like the ones on display upstairs.
他的名字叫杰西，他在空旷的洗碗房里独自工作，从一台巨大的30英尺长的传送带式机器上卸下盘子，就像楼上展出的一样。
Well, do you think there's anything our radio audience should know about the man behind the scenes down here in the dish room?
好吧，你认为我们的广播听众应该了解关于这里洗碗房幕后人的什么事吗？
No, I've really got nothing to say, except that I like the job. It's keeping me out of trouble out there on the streets and everything, you know? It's kind of hard work. The employers are nice people, you know? They're easy to get along with.
没有，我真的没什么可说的，除了我喜欢这份工作。它让我在街上免受麻烦等等，你知道吗？这是辛苦工作。雇主们是好人，你知道吗？他们很容易相处。
As Jesse returned to the head of the machine once again to load dishes into it, I felt at ease for the first time all day. I watched Jesse loading the machine from afar, feeling like I needed to speak with him more, that our bond needed to be acknowledged. But then I noticed the clean dishes exiting the machine, and I knew what to do. I put down the tape recorder and got to work. I walked over and unloaded the clean dishes.
当杰西再次回到机器头部装载盘子时，我一天中第一次感到轻松。我远远地看着杰西装载机器，觉得我需要和他多交流，我们需要确认我们的纽带。但后来我注意到干净的盘子从机器里出来，我知道该怎么做了。我放下录音机，开始工作。我走过去卸下干净的盘子。
Dishwasher Pete a.k.a. Pete Jordan, his original zines about washing dishes in every state were collected into a book called Dishwasher. These days, he lives in Amsterdam and runs Radical Honesty workshops all over Europe. His website, www.honestyeurope.com.
洗碗工皮特，原名皮特·乔丹，他关于在每个州洗碗的原创杂志被收集成了一本书，名为《洗碗工》。如今，他住在阿姆斯特丹，并在欧洲各地举办“激进诚实”研讨会。他的网站，www.honestyeurope.com。
[MUSIC - "BORN TO DO DISHES" BY THE QUEERS]
[音乐 - The Queers的“BORN TO DO DISHES”]
Act Three, When Worlds Collide. So this next story begins at a convention. Well, really, two conventions. John Perry Barlow was at a convention in 1993 for the NeXT computer. That's the machine that Steve Jobs created after he co-founded Apple computers. The other convention going on at the same time was the American Psychiatric Association.
第三幕，当世界碰撞时。下一个故事始于一个会议。嗯，其实是两个会议。约翰·佩里·巴洛在1993年参加了一个NeXT电脑的会议。那就是史蒂夫·乔布斯在联合创立苹果电脑公司后创造的机器。与此同时进行的另一个会议是美国精神病学协会。
And our story starts at the border between those two. John Perry Barlow was a former rancher, song lyricist. And when we first heard the story back in the day, he was head of the Electronic Frontier Foundation. He traveled everywhere, talking about computers. And that is what brought him to the Moscone Center in San Francisco for this convention in 1993.
我们的故事始于这两者之间的边界。约翰·佩里·巴洛是一位前牧场主、歌曲作词人。当我们过去第一次听到这个故事时，他是电子前沿基金会的负责人。他到处旅行，谈论电脑。这就是把他带到旧金山莫斯康中心参加1993年这次会议的原因。
And I was supposed to be giving a-- I was supposed to be the MC at a Steve Jobs celebrity roast. And across the way, the psychiatrists were having a seminar or something. So--
我本应该做个——我本应该在史蒂夫·乔布斯的名人烤肉聚会上做主持人。而在对面，精神病学家们正在举办研讨会之类的。所以——
Before we even go anywhere, I mean, it really does sound like a when worlds collide sort of thing.
在我们去任何地方之前，我的意思是，这听起来确实像是世界碰撞的那种东西。
Oh, totally. Yeah, yeah, it was.
哦，完全是。是的，是的，确实是。
Because the thing about a convention is that each world is so distinctly its own world with its own concerns and its own priorities and its own paradigm.
因为会议的事情在于，每个世界都如此独特地成为自己的世界，有自己的担忧、优先级和范式。
Oh, yeah, and both of these groups of people were so distinct from one another. I mean, psychiatrists, as a group, have a look. And NeXT users-- NeXT was one of the only computers I've ever been around where the whole notion of design was really important to the product-- elegance of design. And it attracted the strangest kind of hybrid, which was sort of like UNIX weenies by Armani combination.
哦，是的，这两群人彼此都非常不同。我的意思是，精神病学家作为一个群体，有一种长相。而NeXT用户——NeXT是我曾经接触过的唯一电脑之一，其中整个设计的概念对产品真的很重要——设计的优雅。而且它吸引了最奇怪的一种混合体，有点像是阿玛尼风格的UNIX极客组合。
OK, and describe what the psychiatrists tend to look like. What was their look?
好的，描述一下精神病学家往往长什么样。他们的样子是什么？
Well, the psychiatrists were all the sort of Jules Feiffer cartoon psychiatrists, tweed jackets, slightly rumpled, and no distinct difference between the men and the women, really, except for this one person. I was standing outside the entrance to the ballroom where I was going to supposedly roast Mr. Jobs. And the psychiatrists were all milling around over there in their corner. And I saw a woman standing with her back to me. And she actually looked dressed to be more one of us than one of them in the sense that she had this very crisp Armani look from behind-- long blond hair.
嗯，精神病学家都是那种朱尔斯·费弗卡通里的精神病学家，粗花呢夹克，略显凌乱，男人和女人之间真的没有明显的区别，除了这个人。我当时站在我本应烤史蒂夫·乔布斯先生的宴会厅入口外。精神病学家们都在那边的角落里四处走动。我看到一个女人背对着我站着。她实际上看起来打扮得更像是我们中的一员，而不是他们中的一员，因为从背后看，她有这种非常干练的阿玛尼外观——长长的金发。
And she turned and looked over her left shoulder and looked right at me. And I've never had an experience like this before or since. I mean, I've always thought that the whole idea of love at first sight was one of those things that was invented by lady novelists with three names from the south, right?
她转过身，从左肩看过来，直视我。我从来没有过这样的经历，无论是在这之前还是之后。我的意思是，我一直认为一见钟情这个概念是那些有三个名字的南方女小说家发明的，对吧？
Right.
对。
Because how can this work? What's the process by which you would recognize something that profound? She looked, and we started looking at each other. And we didn't avert our gaze, either of us, for probably 45 seconds. I mean, we just locked on the beam. And I felt like I was having a hallucination. I mean, I felt like I was hearing voices. It was the strangest thing. And I kind of stepped back and rubbed my eyes and tried to figure out what I was going to do about this.
因为这怎么能奏效呢？你认出如此深刻的东西的过程是什么？她看着，我们开始互相对视。我们都没有移开目光，我们俩，大概持续了45秒。我的意思是，我们只是锁定了光束。我觉得我产生了幻觉。我的意思是，我觉得我在听到声音。这是最奇怪的事情。我有点退后，揉了揉眼睛，试图弄清楚我要怎么处理这件事。
You literally rubbed your eyes?
你真的揉了揉眼睛？
Literally. No, it was an odd-- the whole thing just felt really dreamlike.
真的。不，这很奇怪——整件事感觉真的很梦幻。
I was going to say, it's like in a story.
我本来想说，就像在故事里一样。
It went into this surreal state. And so finally, I thought, well, whatever's going on between this person and me, I am definitely not going to let this moment pass without investigation because I haven't experienced this before. So I circled her a couple of times. And then finally, I came over to her, and I said, "You're something." And she said, "So are you."
它进入了这种超现实的状态。所以最后，我想，好吧，无论这个人和我之间发生了什么，我绝对不会让这一刻在没有调查的情况下过去，因为我以前没有经历过这个。所以我围着她转了几圈。最后，我走到她身边，我说，“你很特别。”她说，“你也是。”
And I said, "Well, where are you from?" And she said-- I mean, I didn't know. I assumed that she was part of our show. I thought that, actually, what she was-- it didn't occur to me that she was associated with the psychiatrists because she didn't look anything like them. And I thought that what she probably was what is-- I wish there were better term for this, but the general computer trade show term for this is booth bimbo, which is somebody who stands in the booth selling the incredibly difficult to use software, who's actually a model or an actress or something who doesn't know anything about the software, but the marketers sort of dangle her out as bait. And then once she's gotten these poor innocent hackers to wander over so they can talk to the beautiful girl, then, wham, they get them.
我说，“你从哪里来？”她说——我的意思是，我不知道。我以为她是我们要看的节目的一部分。其实，我想的是，她是什么——我不希望有更好的术语来表达这个，但一般的电脑展术语是“展台宝贝”，也就是站在展台里销售极其难以使用的软件的人，实际上是个模特或演员之类的，对软件一无所知，但营销人员把她当成诱饵。然后一旦她诱使那些可怜无辜的黑客过来，好让他们和美丽的女孩交谈，砰，他们就中招了。
Right, geeks move in.
对，极客们开始行动。
Right, the geeks move in and hustle them off and sell them software. And-- but I just assumed--
对，极客们开始行动，把他们拉过去，向他们推销软件。而且——但我只是认为——
Time honored practice.
历史悠久的习俗。
Right, exactly. It works. And so I just assumed she must be a booth bimbo because she was much too beautiful to be, well, a computer hacker.
对，完全正确。这很管用。所以我只是认为她一定是个展台宝贝，因为她太漂亮了，不可能是个黑客。
Or a psychiatrist.
或者是精神病学家。
Oh, and that didn't even dawn on me that she was a psychiatrist, which, in fact, she was. But I said, well, where are you from? And she said, well, I'm from a little town in British Columbia. And I said, well, that's interesting. I'm from a little town in Wyoming, which is kind of like British Columbia. Where do you live now? And she said New York. And I said, well, that's even more interesting because that's where I live. I said, where do you live in New York? And she said 19th and Third.
哦，我甚至没意识到她是精神病学家，实际上她确实是。但我说，你从哪里来？她说，嗯，我来自不列颠哥伦比亚省的一个小镇。我说，嗯，那很有趣。我来自怀俄明州的一个小镇，有点像不列颠哥伦比亚省。你现在住哪儿？她说纽约。我说，嗯，那更有趣，因为那是我住的地方。我说，你住在纽约哪儿？她说第19街和第三大道。
And I said, well, that's not too far from where I live. I'm down at the lower end of Fifth Avenue. And she said, where? And I said, well, Fifth and Ninth. And she said, really, which building? And I said it's the old Fifth Avenue Hotel. It's 24 Fifth Avenue. And she said, really? Well, it turns out that I just got an apartment in that building. In fact, she had just gotten an apartment precisely two stories above mine in the same building.
我说，嗯，那离我住的地方不远。我在第五大道下端。她说，哪儿？我说，第五大道和第九街。她说，真的吗，哪栋楼？我说那是老第五大道酒店。第五大道24号。她说，真的吗？结果发现我刚在那栋楼里租了一套公寓。事实上，她恰好搬到了我楼上两层，同一栋楼里。
So there I was with this woman that I had an instantaneous and inexplicable attachment to who was about to move into my apartment building. And we just went off together and, actually, moved in together, really, literally, a week after we met.
所以我就和这个我瞬间产生无法解释的依恋的女人在一起了，她就要搬进我的公寓楼。我们就一起离开了，实际上，真的，我们见面一周后就住在一起了。
So when you're at the convention with her, you just spent all your time together basically.
所以当你在会议上和她在一起时，你们基本上把所有时间都花在一起了。
Uh, yeah, from that point forward. And it was a great opportunity for me to introduce her to my world in a lot of its other dimensions, because the Grateful Dead was having a concert in Sacramento one of the nights of these giant conventions. And so we went over, and she saw her first Dead concert. And this is a person who would never have been caught dead at a Dead concert.
嗯，是的，从那时起。这也是我向她介绍我的世界其他维度的绝佳机会，因为感恩而死乐队在这些巨型会议的一天晚上在萨克拉门托开音乐会。所以我们去了，她第一次看了感恩而死演唱会。这是一个永远不会去感恩而死演唱会的人。
Explain your connection with the Grateful Dead.
解释一下你和感恩而死乐队的关系。
Oh, I spent many, many years as their sort of junior varsity songwriter. There were two songwriters, and I was the lesser of the two.
哦，我做了很多年的少年二线作词人。有两个作词人，我是其中较弱的一个。
And so what did she think of the concert? What did she make of it?
那么她觉得演唱会怎么样？她怎么看？
She liked it a lot. She thought the Deadheads were fascinating. She thought the music was great. I mean, but the other thing was that we were just completely hopelessly besotted with each other. I mean, I could have taken her to a dogfight, I think, and she would have thought it was OK. It was just one of those completely unexpected acts of providence, where two worlds collided, and something wonderful came from the point that they touched.
她很喜欢。她觉得“感恩而死”粉丝很迷人。她觉得音乐很棒。我的意思是，但另一件事是我们对彼此完全无望地痴迷。我的意思是，我想即使我带她去斗狗场，她也会觉得还可以。这只是那些完全出乎意料的各种天意之一，两个世界碰撞了，当它们接触的那一点产生了一些美妙的东西。
Do you think that if you would have met this woman in some other setting, just on the street or seeing her in the lobby of the apartment building that you lived in after she had moved in there, do you think that you would have had this moment quite so powerfully?
你认为如果你在其他地方遇到这个女人，只是在街上，或者在她搬进去后在公寓大厅看到她，你认为你会如此强烈地拥有这一刻吗？
Well--
好吧——
Or do you think that there was something about being at a convention where one is just open to experience in a way that one wouldn't be elsewhere?
还是你认为参加会议有什么特别之处，一个人只是以在其他地方不会有的方式对经验持开放态度？
Actually, I think, at that moment, she was more inclined to judge things more on the basis of their appearance. And what she mainly saw was a guy in a real sharp suit. The next day when I returned to my normal style of dress, she said, well, wait a second. Is this how you usually dress? And I said, yeah. And she said, oh, well, all right.
其实，我认为，在那一刻，她更倾向于根据外观来评判事物。而她主要看到的是一个穿着非常时髦西装的男人。第二天当我恢复正常的穿衣风格时，她说，嗯，等等。这是你通常的穿衣方式吗？我说，是啊。她说，哦，好吧。
But do you think that if you had seen her just walking into your building three weeks after that for the first time--
但你认为如果你在三周后第一次看到她走进你的楼里——
I think--
我想——
--do you think that this moment would have happened?
——你认为这一刻会发生吗？
I think that it probably would have happened anyway. There was something about this particular connection that would have overridden any of the surrounding noise in the data. I mean, I felt like I had finally met another member of my tribe and felt that before I said anything to her or she said anything to me.
我认为它可能还是会发生。这种特定的联系有什么东西会覆盖数据中所有的周围噪音。我的意思是，我觉得我终于遇到了我的部落的另一个成员，并且在我对她说什么或者她对我说什么之前就感觉到了。
What happened with her finally?
她最后怎么了？
Well, what happened was we had both had the flu. And she was a young woman, I mean, quite a bit younger than me. And very healthy-- took extremely good care of herself. Athletic and-- but we both had the flu, and it had been a real nasty flu. And it had us both kind of hitting on maybe five out of eight for close to a month.
嗯，发生了什么是我们都得了流感。她是一个年轻女子，我的意思是，比我年轻得多。而且非常健康——对自己照顾得非常好。运动型——但我们都得了流感，那是一种真正严重的流感。它让我们俩在近一个月里可能只有八分之五的状态。
Yeah.
是的。
And I had gone out to Los Angeles to give a speech. And Tim Leary had gotten some tickets to a Pink Floyd concert at the Rose Bowl. And she was going to come out and join me to go to this Pink Floyd concert with Tim. That all got bollixed up. We ended up going by ourselves, having a very long, complicated evening with a lot of waiting in traffic and looking for a car and whatnot and--
我去洛杉矶发表演讲。蒂姆·利里搞到了一些在玫瑰碗举行平克·弗洛伊德音乐会的票。她要出来加入我，和蒂姆一起去看平克·弗洛伊德音乐会。那一切都搞砸了。我们最后是自己去的，度过了一个非常漫长、复杂的夜晚，有很多等待交通和找车之类的——
Going off by yourselves, you and Timothy Leary or you and her?
你们自己去，你和蒂莫西·利里，还是你和她？
Cynthia and me.
辛西娅和我。
OK, yeah.
好的，是的。
And over the course of this evening, we decided that even though we had been sort of the opinion that we didn't want to think about the future that much, she said, well, I know that we're not supposed to think about the future. But I think that you and I should have children. And if we're going to do that, I would love to start soon. And if we're going to do that, then we should be married. How do you feel about those things? And I said, fine, sure. No problem.
在这一天晚上，我们决定，尽管我们一直认为我们不想过多考虑未来，她说，嗯，我知道我们不应该考虑未来。但我认为你和我应该有孩子。如果我们打算这样做，我想尽快开始。如果我们打算这样做，那么我们就应该结婚。你对这些事情感觉如何？我说，好的，当然。没问题。
Anyway, the next day, I had a meeting, and the next day was a Sunday. And I had a red eye back to New York that evening, and Cynthia was going to go on then. And I said, look, you've been sick, and you've got patients tomorrow. Why don't you just take an afternoon flight? And I'll be home to see you before you go off to work. And so she took an afternoon flight, and I took her down to the airport and gave each other a great big kiss. And she said, nothing can keep us apart, baby. We were made for each other.
不管怎样，第二天我有一个会议，第二天是周日。那天晚上我有一班回纽约的红眼航班，辛西娅当时也要去。我说，看，你生病了，明天还要看病人。你为什么不搭下午的飞机呢？我会回家见到你，然后你去工作。所以她搭了下午的飞机，我送她去机场，吻别。她说，没有什么能把我们分开，宝贝。我们是天造地设的一对。
And she just walked onto the plane and went to sleep, took a nap, and it turned out that the virus that we both had, the flu virus, had attacked her heart and had been chewing away on it for the previous 10 days or so. And it pretty well consumed the pericardium. And so, eventually, it was so compromised that as she was sleeping, she started to fibrillate and just died. And she was two days short of her 30th birthday. And they went to tell her to put her seat belt on coming into JFK. She was dead and had been for a while.
她就这样走上飞机，睡着了，小睡了一会儿，结果我们俩都患上的那个病毒，那个流感病毒，攻击了她的心脏，并且在过去10天左右的时间里一直在侵蚀它。它几乎完全消耗了心包。所以，最终，它受到了严重的损害，以至于当她睡觉时，她开始心室颤动，然后就死了。她距离30岁生日还有两天。飞机准备降落肯尼迪机场时，他们去告诉她系上安全带。她已经去世了，而且已经有一段时间了。
Oh, my god.
哦，天哪。
So I mean, this whole episode from the moment I saw her there in the hallway of the ANA to the moment where I watched her walk onto the aircraft was one of the really central passages of my life. And after that, everything was different.
我的意思是，从我在ANA大厅看到她的那一刻到我看着她走上飞机的那一刻，这段插曲是我人生中真正核心的章节之一。在那之后，一切都不同了。
And smaller.
而且更小了。
Well, no, actually, I wouldn't say that. In many ways, not at all, because one of the things that came out of it was that prior to this, I didn't believe in the soul. I mean, I think that within us were two spirits that had all-- I mean, there's really just no way to say this without sounding incredibly sappy. But we were the same soul. And having seen that, that changes everything.
嗯，不，其实，我不会那样说。在很多方面，完全不是，因为由此产生的事情之一是，在此之前，我不相信灵魂。我的意思是，我认为在我们之内有两个灵魂——我的意思是，如果不听起来非常伤感，真的没有办法说出来。但我们是同一个灵魂。看到了这一点，就改变了一切。
Now that you had this experience with her, do you find that you have this experience all the time in a smaller forum, where you'll meet a group of strangers, and there'll be one whose eyes strikes you, and you think, OK, I could see a part of this thing?
既然你有了她这种经历，你发现你是否一直在一个小论坛上有这种经历，在那里你会遇到一群陌生人，其中有一个人的眼睛让你印象深刻，你想，好的，我能看到这东西的一部分？
Absolutely. I mean, I feel an ability to attach on a moment to moment basis that is completely unlike anything that I felt prior to that. And I think it's sometimes a little disconcerting to other people, because it's genuine on my side. And people are not used to having somebody just dock emotionally that instantaneously. For one thing, I feel like I can see their souls. Their souls are visible to me.
绝对。我的意思是，我感觉到一种随时可以依附的能力，这与我在那之前感觉到的任何东西都完全不同。而且我认为有时这会让其他人有点不安，因为我这边是真诚的。人们不习惯有人那样瞬间在情感上对接。首先，我觉得我可以看到他们的灵魂。他们的灵魂对我来说是可见的。
One of the things that happened as a consequence of this is that, for a while there, if I had stopped moving, the pain got so bad that I couldn't stand it. So I fell into a lifestyle of continuous motion. And that gradually became an economic adaptation. And now I just simply live on the road pretty much. I mean, I flew 270 some odd thousand miles last year just on one airline.
作为一个后果发生的事情之一是，在那段时间里，如果我停止移动，痛苦就会变得如此糟糕，以至于我无法忍受。所以我陷入了一种持续运动的生活方式。那逐渐变成了一种经济适应。现在我简直就是生活在路上。我的意思是，去年我仅在一家航空公司就飞了27万英里。
God damn. I mean, I'm just hearing you say it. It's like you want to die on a plane, too.
该死。我的意思是，我只是听到你这么说。感觉你也不想死在飞机上。
Well, it's a funny thing. No, I'm not particularly interested in dying on a plane. But I mean, that's kind of like, I really feel like the stratosphere is my church.
嗯，这很有趣。不，我对死在飞机上没什么特别兴趣。但我的意思是，那有点像是，我真的觉得平流层是我的教堂。
That's where you feel like you can contact her.
那就是你觉得可以联系到她的地方。
Well, kind of. I mean, I feel there's something about being up there that makes me feel like I'm closer to her, yeah.
嗯，某种程度上。我的意思是，我觉得在那里待着让我觉得我离她更近，是的。
No, I totally understand that, because it's the last place where she was.
不，我完全理解这一点，因为那是她待过的最后一个地方。
Yeah, but it's more than that. I mean, last night, I was flying here to Salt Lake from New York. And I looked out, and it was just-- I don't know that I believe in heaven or anything quite like that. But I mean, it looked exactly like heaven in the paintings of that period of the late Renaissance when they really started to get light and understand how to do light and clouds.
是的，但不仅如此。我的意思是，昨晚，我正从纽约飞往盐湖城。我向外看，这只是——我不知道我是否相信天堂或类似的东西。但我的意思是，它看起来完全像晚文艺复兴时期那些画作中的天堂，那时他们真正开始获得光线，了解如何处理光线和云。
Yeah, that really clear kind of blue.
是的，那种非常清澈的蓝色。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
They're like pale, clear blue.
它们像苍白、清澈的蓝色。
There were layers and layers and layers of different colors of clouds. And they were all catching the sunlight in golds and blues. And I thought, well, what a great life it is that puts you in this unbelievably holy environment on such a regular basis.
云有层层叠叠的不同颜色。它们都在捕捉金色和蓝色的阳光。我想，好吧，拥有一个让你如此定期地处于这种令人难以置信的神圣环境中的生活是多么棒啊。
For me, that would be the additional thing-- and I wonder if this is for you, too-- that I mean, maybe this is going off now because you fly so much. But I mean, every time I would get on a plane, I would just think, OK, this is her setting. You know what I mean? It's like, this is where I left her. And she could be in any one of these seats. And it would be very hard for me to not be picturing her in one of those seats and just sleeping.
对我来说，那是额外的东西——我不知道这是否也是你的情况——我的意思是，也许现在这样说是因为你飞得太多了。但我的意思是，每次我上飞机，我都会想，好的，这是她的环境。你知道我的意思吗？就像，这是我离开她的地方。她可能在这些座位中的任何一个。要我不去想象她坐在其中一个座位上睡觉是非常困难的。
Yeah, no, I mean, she's there.
是的，不，我的意思是，她在那里。
Even now. Even just--
即使现在。即使只是——
Oh, sure, yeah. No, I mean, as I say, it's not something that goes away, as far as I can tell. It's a permanent fixture. And that's OK. I mean, I'm glad to have it. But anyway, it was a hell of a convention, you know? I mean, I'm sure glad I went to that Steve Jobs celebrity roast.
哦，当然，是的。不，我的意思是，正如我所说，据我所知，这不是一种会消失的东西。这是一个永久的固定装置。没关系。我的意思是，我很高兴拥有它。但不管怎样，那是个地狱般的会议，你知道吗？我的意思是，我真高兴我去参加了那个史蒂夫·乔布斯名人烤肉聚会。
John Perry Barlow. I am so sorry to say that he died back in 2018.
约翰·佩里·巴洛。我很抱歉地说，他在2018年去世了。
Well, today's program was produced back in the 1990s by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder, senior editor for today's show, Paul Tough, contributing editors, Jack Hitt, Margie Rochlin, and consiliere Sarah Vowell. Additional production help on today's rerun from Stowe Nelson, Ari Saperstein, and Matt Tierney. John Conners, who you heard in Act One going to the Dark Shadows convention, is in the band Bric Brac. You can find them on Spotify, Apple Music, or wherever you get your music.
今天节目的内容是由南希·厄普代克和我本人在1990年代制作的，还有阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德，今天的节目的高级编辑，保罗·塔夫，特约编辑，杰克·希特，玛吉·罗克林，以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。今天重播的额外制作帮助来自斯托·尼尔森，阿里·萨珀斯坦和马特·蒂尔尼。约翰·康纳斯，你们在第一幕中听到他去参加《暗影》会议，他是Bric Brac乐队的成员。你们可以在Spotify、Apple Music或你们获取音乐的任何地方找到他们。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Torey, just, why don't you say it?
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你们可以完全免费收听我们超过700集的存档节目。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。托里，就，你为什么不说了？
No, I don't want to say it any louder. I don't want to say it any louder. No, I don't want to say it. It's OK. I've said it.
不，我不想再大声说了。我不想再大声说了。不，我不想说。没关系。我已经说了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
Dark Shadows lives!
《暗影》万岁！
[MUSIC - "BLACK-THROATED WIND" BY GRATEFUL DEAD]
[音乐 - Grateful Dead的“BLACK-THROATED WIND”]
Next week on the podcast of This American Life, for lots of us, when we try to describe our siblings to people, we have a story we tell to illustrate what they're like. And Emanuele's sister has a story like that about her.
下周在《美国生活》播客，对于我们许多人来说，当我们尝试向人们描述我们的兄弟姐妹时，我们有一个故事来展示他们是什么样的人。而伊曼纽尔的姐姐有一个关于她的故事。
It's not that flattering.
那并不讨人喜欢。
It's not that flattering?
那并不讨人喜欢？
No, I mean, it's just-- it was just the time that you punched me in the eye. You were like--
不，我的意思是，它只是——这只是你打我眼睛的那次。你当时——
Sisters and the very particular things that happen between them. Next week on the podcast or on your local public radio station.
姐妹之间发生的非常特殊的事情。下周在播客或你们当地的公共广播电台收听。